first I'd like to introduce myself my
name is Liz to and I lead the um product
management programs on the professional
education side um Pax would you like to
introduce yourself hi everyone welcome
and thank you for joining us my name is
PAX heire I'm the director of academic
programs here at Stanford online in the
center for professional development so
we're going to go in a little bit more
detail about what academic programs are
versus professional programs um and I
wanted to start to give you kind of a
preview of the the content we'll be
covering and a little bit about us
generally and then Liz and I will go
into more detail about specific programs
so in terms of our product management
offerings and in general across the
Stanford online portfolio we have a lot
of different kinds of offerings that are
meant to kind of meet you where you are
as a learner so we have a a lot of free
content webinars like this but also a
lot of webinars with faculty and
teaching teams including uh the teaching
teams for these these product management
courses so you can go to Stanford
online's uh website or the Stanford
online YouTube channel and see a lot of
content we already have there in
addition there's a program preview and
this is for the professional program and
it'll give you a sense of what the
course experience is for that program
it's also a preview for some of the
credit bearing classes that I'll get
into a little bit um because the same
some of the same teaching team is
involved in the professional as well as
the credit bearing programs so it's a
good it's a good preview actually for
for both kinds of offerings uh these
this free content is a great way for you
to just get to know the content to
understand what the experience might be
like H this would be perfect for you if
you're not sure about taking a full
course or you just want to dip your toe
into this topic in addition to the free
content we have professional uh
educational offerings and this is what
Liz will go into more Det detail and you
can you see we have three listed here
the individual courses um the all access
plan as well as the product management
acceler you kind of think of these
building into each other so the
individual courses um most of them are
around nine 10 hours uh you can take
just a single course maybe there's one
Topic in this broader program that you
want to Deep dive in or there's only one
thing you really want to explore or
you're not sure the whole program is
right for you so you want to take a
single course you can do that you can
also put them all together into the all
access plan and if you complete four of
them and you can do this by pursuing
individual courses as well you can earn
a certificate and so this allows you to
go a deeper dive into the topic explore
lots of areas and then finally there's
the product management accelerated which
puts all those things together into a
cohort experience and that gives you the
benefits of a community of of Learners
going through the material at the same
time as well as some teaching support
and Liz is going to go into a lot more
detail about those uh different
offerings under the professional we also
have academic credit offerings so this
is uh maybe the the best kept or the
least kept secret at Sanford is there
are a lot of programs courses that are
happening on campus that you also have
the opportunity to attend as an online
student so you would be enrolled in the
same course as it is happening on campus
you would be an online student but you
would be working with the same faculty
or teaching team you'd be working with
the Stanford students you'd be doing the
same materials you would be earning a
grade and you would be getting Stanford
uh Stanford uh earning a Stanford
transcript in Stanford Credit so we're
going to go into a lot more detail about
those uh offerings as well later on in
the presentation uh but we just wanted
to lay that out that kind of road map
out here to begin so Liz I'm going to
hand it back to you to go into a little
bit more detail on those professional
offerings sure um so now we're going to
focus more on professional education uh
so you can think of our offerings
divided into two categories we have our
self-paced offerings and the instructor
paced offering uh so self-pace means
exactly what it sound sounds like you
can sign up at your own convenience and
complete the courses at your own pace so
you could complete a course in a single
day or Str stretch it out over the
course of 60 days upon completing an
individual course you receive a record
of
completion um you can also pursue the
full program credential which Pax kind
of mentioned um so it requires you to
complete two required courses and two of
the four electives if you opt for that
um the all access plan is a maybe a
better fit since it offers um it makes
available all six individual courses at
a discounted price um and if you opt
into the all access plan you can
complete the courses over the course of
a year we also have the accelerated
program which you can think of as a
different modality of completing the um
all access plan so it's the same lecture
is just packaged into 10 weeks and you
work with a group to complete your
Capstone um you ALS also get additional
support from a team of experienced PMS
who coach you throughout the program uh
this program is instructor base so that
means the teaching Team sets the
schedule for each program run so you
have weekly assignments that you work on
with your group which means there's less
flexibility if there are other factors
in your life um that could prevent you
from
studying um and now an overview of the
self-paced courses so you can see we
have the free program preview which has
already talked about it does not Grant
any type of um certificate or record of
completion it's just intended to give
you a taste of what the courses are like
um we have the two required courses
product management transforming
opportunities into great products
mastering product management and
building your strategy and then we have
four elective courses so again to um
receive your full certificate for the
product management program you need to
complete these two required courses and
then two of the four elective courses
you see here
um and now a quick overview of how the
courses are structured in the self-paced
program so there are no prerequisites um
you you know you don't need to know
anything about product management you
don't need to have any technical skill
set to take these
courses um all the courses have recorded
lectures with Stanford stamer um faculty
inst structures um within the course in
addition to the lectures you have
written exercises and a multiple choice
final assessment so the passing the
multiple choice final assessment is um
you must pass it in order to receive
your record of completion so there are
20 multiple choice questions at the end
of the course you must score at least
85% to pass the course and you can
reattempt the um final assessment if you
do not pass the first
time um you also get support from course
facilitators via email so within the
course you have the option of ask asking
the teaching team if you need
clarifications about something and one
of our course facilitators will you know
engage with you over email um over about
your
questions um and then you know even if
you are very certain that you want to
take a particular course we still
encourage you to enroll in the program
preview it's free and gives you a taste
of what the courses are like how they're
structured um the types of cover topics
that are covered um and you get all that
before making any real Financial
commitment to the
program um and then moving on to the
accelerated program so as you can see
from this graphic this program takes
content from the six product management
courses we've already um mentioned and
Cates it into a single 10-e program so
the videos you watch are sourced from
these courses and a lot of the
assignments are also adapted from
exercises Within These
courses and then uh just a quick
overview of how the this um program is
structured so again no formal
prerequisites but there is an
expectation sense um part of the
experience is so dependent on working
with your group and engaging with your
peers that you are ready to you know
work with your peers in with your group
to complete your um group
assignments uh the lectures are the same
as the ones in the self-paced courses in
addition to the lectures we have
coaching sessions and live sessions with
guests we
you can think of coaching sessions as um
additional time with our coaching team
to dive deeper into what the lectures
has
covered um you also get personalized
feedback on your weekly assignments from
your coaches um and you know your
coaches work with you throughout the
program to make sure you're on track to
complete the
Capstone um you have written assignments
and a final Capstone presentation and
that is like the culmination of
everything you've worked on throughout
the program
and lastly you know in addition to the
time you spend with your peers in the
coaching sessions and when you get
together to work on your assignments we
have a slack community so that's always
an open Communication channel uh between
everyone in the program and the teaching
team and uh a little more on the coaches
so I do think this is one of the key
differentiators between the um
accelerated program and the self-paced
program is your access to your Cod
coaches so you know they provide support
through these weekly coaching sessions
slack and email and then if your group
needs additional time you can also
schedule on demand office hours um each
week we have two we have coaching
sessions that we offer at two times so
Wednesdays at 5:00 pm and Thursdays at
9:00 amm Pacific time this is just to
try to accommodate people's schedules
and different time zones um the content
covered in the um in both sessions are
the same and just the delivery may be
different depending on how uh depending
on who the coach is that's leading
it um and then if you're not able to
attend the sessions live these are also
recorded and uploaded into the
course and then another key
differentiator is the peer-to-peer
interaction so this mostly happens
through you're working with your group
um so the Capstone project the Capstone
is a group project and it takes you
throughout the product life cycle so we
strongly believe that product managers
rarely work individually and that a
group project like this will better
prepare you for um any career in product
management so we do our best to so we
sign people into groups based off of
their responses in a pre-course survey
in this survey you have the option to
list preferences like you know industry
geographic location Etc and we do our
best to match folks but we cannot
guarantee we can commodate all the
preferences
and then uh just wanted to give an
example of what a typical what a week
looks like in the course so you can see
this is from the most recent cohort in
the past fall um it's kind of a lecture
heavy week um we also have optional
lectures if you know people want to dive
deeper into the topic those are in
italics we have a coaching session that
week that focused on us their research
how to conduct it and then there was an
extra there was a live session with one
of the instructors Julie Stanford on
need finding and then the assignment
that week was to um write a research
plan with your
group and then this is just a sample of
live events in the cohort so we have the
coaching sessions which we've already
talked about the Capone presentation
which you have the option presenting
live or submitting a recording of um and
then we had four live sessions with
different guest speakers so you can see
we had one on need finding product
strategy and an open Q&A with different
instructors in the program and then we
had a careers panel with um different
working PMS on um just generally uh jobs
and product management and
advice and let me see if we have um any
questions to answer there's some good
questions that maybe I can uh jump in
and just uh direct to you so there's a
question about the credentials for the
all access plan versus the Exel at and I
understand that the they are slightly
different right there's a certificate of
completion for the uh completing it in
the self-paced version and the
accelerated is a is what we call a
certificate of achievement and maybe uh
if Sarah or someone who's on online
helping us with the questions if you
could just push out to the audience the
credential framework uh from our website
and so that can help explain the
differences in those in those different
Stanford credentials but basically the
idea is the certificate of completion is
less rigorous than the certificate of
achievement right more time is is is
required in order to earn the
certificate of achievement a great
question um Liz there is also a a
question about um the the accelerated
program do students pursuing their
accelerated program get full access to
the materials or is it a curated
selection of the material so it is uh
full access to all the content so we're
not able to fit quite everything into
the 10 weeks and so we also you know you
have access to the entire course for a
year just like the all access plan um so
the extra lectures that aren't fitted
into the 10we schedule you can revisit
at your own
pace fantastic and then uh there was a
specific question as well for the
self-paced program is there any slack
access with that my assumption is no
that there's not but no there's no slack
access with the self-paced program so
just the emails support through the ask
the teaching team and so again with the
the self-pace because we're getting
there's some confusion around you just
you work through the uh you work through
the um but you just work through the
material on your own pace you can ask
questions via email but there are no
additional sessions or q&as with the
teaching team that is that's all for the
accelerated program correct
yes um and then uh yeah I'm not seeing
there some other there a couple other
questions that maybe we can address I
see there's a question about discounts
if you're a Stanford student I'd say
reach out to scpd directly if you have
that question once you're a Stanford
student there are uh some some uh
discounts for for people affiliated with
Stanford but uh yeah I'd reach out to us
directly once you're uh
matriculated the and then Liz can you
talk maybe about the start dates again
for the accelerated program so um I know
we'll go over this at the end but there
is also that question yeah so generally
the um accelerate program is offered
three times a year once in the spring
once in the summer and once in the fall
so the next cohort um starts January
31st and runs through I can't read the
date off the top of my head but um like
early mid April and so uh registration
is open for that cohort now on the
course
page thanks L I think there are some
other questions but maybe we'll come
back to Q&A at the end of the session so
again thank you all for being here and
asking your questions if we don't get
them all uh you know we'll get to as
many as we can so I'm going to take over
uh driving here for a second and I'm
going to O give you an overview of the
credit bearing courses so as you learn
from Liz there's a lot of flexibility in
the way you can approach the
professional courses you can kind of
choose the product that fits you and and
the time you have and the commit
commitment you want to make to to
learning this material the credit
bearing courses so Stanford also makes
available uh and let me just jump into
this next slide uh every single quarter
I'm going to give you a broad overview
of the credit bearing courses and then
programs and then I'm going to go into a
little bit more detail in these
particular uh the particular product
management ones so any given quarter we
have you know 50 to 70 classes that are
happening on campus that Stanford uh is
also extending to online Learners and so
in total there are about 200 courses
mostly from the School of Engineering
that's where scpd uh is is housed
they're about 200 engineering courses
that are offered each year and in
addition to that there are 30
certificates these certificates are
different from the ones and again you
can look at that credential framework
these are graduate certificates these
are accredited by was which is the same
accreditor that does all of Stanford's
accreditation uh and these again are the
same Stanford courses that are happening
on campus and you are responsible for
completing the same material for doing
the same assignments you're learning
alongside the the the Stanford students
you earn a Stanford transcript you get a
grade
um but you're not admitted into Stanford
right this is a really unique
opportunity for you to try out a
graduate course take a single course or
pursue a certificate and the advantage
of that is again with lizes you you get
a lot of flexibility you can you can
kind of mix and match how how you want
to approach the time commitment you have
with this we do have to follow the
Stanford quarters so they're all 10we
quarters the next product management
classes start in January and they'll end
in March um and they are 10 we classes
and they are just like a a class that
you had as an undergraduate as a
graduate student they're going to follow
that schedule you have assignments
probably every week and you're working
along uh alongside the the campus
students the advantage is that you don't
have to be enrolled in every quarter
this is a chance for you again to kind
of dip your toe into into a graduate
class or just instead of having to
pursue a whole master's degree or a
whole undergraduate degree you can take
a single class maybe just the one you
need or in this case just a product
management class you can also apply any
qu quarter that a course is offered so
if you want to take a course this winter
you can apply right now to take a course
in in the winter if you want to take a
course in the spring you can apply to
take a course in the spring the summer
the fall right so any quarter a course
is offered you can take it you can apply
you also don't need to be continuously
enrolled so if you say you take this
product management course in in the um
in the winter and then you decide hey I
really like this but you know work is
just way too busy uh I can't do anything
in the spring that's fine you don't need
to take a course in the spring you could
take one in the summer the next fall you
could wait a year to the winter you
could wait longer and take a course you
know a few years down the
road if you are pursuing a a certificate
and I I'll go into a little bit more
detail about those if you're pursuing a
certificate there is a timeline on that
you would need to re complete the
requirements of that certificate within
three
years now to make this program work as I
said you're not admitted into a Stanford
you're you're being approved on a course
byc course basis right and so that
allows us to not have you you don't have
to be continuously enrolled you can just
dip in and take a single course and so
that goes as well for if you're pursuing
a certificate you're kind of approved
you you have a a a desire to pursue
their certificate but you're approved on
a course byour basis um in order uh to
continue to pursue the the certificate
or just take courses you do need to earn
a beer better to keep taking classes um
and again your application is going to
be reviewed each time to make sure that
you're meeting the prerequisites for the
specific class that you're you're you're
applying to
um but it again it's a wonderful
opportunity to kind of dip your toe in
into into graduate education I'll
mention one more thing about this which
is that up to 18 units that you complete
through this program can be transferred
to a Stanford master's degree if the if
the uh courses are applicable to it so
yeah it's a wonderful way to get
exposure to uh Stanford classes I'm
going to go into detail about the
product management classes but I we
already did get a question about Andrew
ing so Andrew in does teach uh graduate
classes Stanford that are open to online
uh professional Learners they're all in
computer science and so you would need
to have a strong Computer Science
Background these aren't like the the
corsera courses these are programs that
would would require um a significant
sort of math and and computer science
background so let me go into a little
bit more detail about the two product
management courses that we will be
offering uh this winter so we have a
introduction to product management and
product management fundamentals and they
do cover very similar material and they
have very similar structure so I think
the core difference here is probably at
the level of the teaching team so the
introduction to product management is
taught by a faculty member in management
science and engineering he uses a book
that he's written he brings in Industry
experts they Tas and they walk you
through a project uh just as as similar
to the one in the professional program
similar to the one in the other graduate
course you'll walk through a project
around improving or creating a new
product putting together a
proposal as I said it's a quarter it's a
10-week course you're going to expect to
spend about 9 to 15 hours is a week in
this course so it has a long duration
similar to the accelerated program but
it's requires a lot more work per week
and this is true of both of these
courses um and that's just because again
you're earning a Stanford transcript
you're earning uh you're you're taking
actual Stanford class so there's a lot
more that's asked of you you're doing a
lot more work there's a lot more uh you
know lecture to cover and uh work to to
do the pr minimum prerequisites for this
introduction to product management uh
are 3.2 undergraduate GPA I'll go into
what the application is and there is an
application required but it does involve
your your your transcripts as well as
multivariable calculus which seems odd I
don't think there's uh there is no
mathematical analysis in the product
management class itself but there are a
lot in the management science and
engineering program so in general that
is a a baseline requirement they ask for
all people who are uh applying to to
take a single course through U through
Stanford online as I said it's Project
based so you would be working with a
team would be likely a mix of SE so
online students as well as on campus
students to improve or create a new Pro
uh product there are lectures that are
recorded twice a week they're happening
in the classroom they're recorded for
you in some cases they may provide an
opportunity for you to join live live
for instance over Zoom to do a
presentation but for the most part these
you would watch these lectures
asynchronously and again the reason for
that is unlike the oncampus students who
are just full-time students uh many of
you will be work and you may not be able
to join the lecture time uh you know
would wouldn't be able to join Over Zoom
at the the set lecture time and finally
in terms of support there are uh weekly
project check-ins as well as office
hours and there is a mentor and and Tas
who are assigned to to help you through
the the project in the
coursework and I should step back and
say one other thing is that because
these are courses that are delivered
every year again and again The Faculty
are constantly refining and developing
the course syllabi and so what I'm
talking about here is how the course was
last delivered Ed The Faculty are right
now in the process of updating and
revising it based on the feedback
they've gotten before so let me jump
over to the product management
fundamentals so if the introduction to
product management is taught by a a
faculty member here who's written a book
on it and has a a strong kind of
theoretical framework or approach to
product management product management
fundamentals is taught by an non and
Jay-Z We the two principal instructors
for the professional program um they are
professional uh product managers here
product managers managers excuse me here
in the Bay Area working at Silicon
Valley type companies and so they're
bringing a wealth of professional
experience and they take a very applied
and Hands-On approach they want to walk
you through that same kind of project in
creating an MVP uh you know minimal
viable project but they're going to take
it through you very much in the way um
in in a very Hands-On way that they
would expect their PMS who they train
and work with to to approach it like the
other one there are industry speakers as
well as a ta who can who will be uh
joining to help you through the program
like the other it's a 10-week it's
follows the quarter system it's 9 to 15
hours a week so it's a pretty intense
commitment um and again if you're
thinking about the the different
programs Liz's the the professional
programs offer you a lot of opportunity
to explore they're more flexible in
terms of the time commitment the
duration and with these you're you're
enrolled in a a graduate level course at
Stanford and so there's it's meant to
provide you a deeper dive and a lot of
rigor the prere minimum pre PR
requisites for this one are 3.0
undergraduate GPA um they do again
that's not the only prerequisites but
those are the minimum for your
application to be considered like the
other one there is a a project it is
what they call the MVP or the minimal
viable project it has kind of four
stages or did last year WR a stage where
you think about and you would learn a
lot more about all these Concepts is you
think through the problem space you
design a solution you come up with a
launch plan and then you develop a road
map for the product development uh
finally this course um will have
recorded lectures but they also really
encourage and want uh even the online
students to join live they see the the
lectures as a critical part and very uh
interactive so those lectures are
delivered in the evenings uh 4:30 to
7:20 pm Pacific Time on Thursdays and
they encourage anyone uh who is enrolled
in the class to join those sessions live
if you cannot because again we know
you're working professional or you may
not be located
in in a time zone where that's uh that
works for you you can watch the recorded
sessions and finally uh in terms of
support they also have office hours so
they're very similar uh programs I
understand there's a you know they they
it can be hard to sort of think through
the differences between the two of them
i' encourage you to take a look at the
course Pages they're linked to in the
resources section uh in your console so
take a look and and think about them in
more detail now both of them again start
at January 8th and they would end around
March 22nd
and uh you in order to enroll or be
considered in order for your application
to be considered you need to submit an
application and submit a request to
enroll in these courses by December 8th
and I'll go over that one more time let
me go in a little bit more detail then
about what that application is so you
don't need to take tests uh you don't
need to you know there's it it again the
application can be submitted at any time
it's not considered until you uh you you
actually submit a request to enroll in a
course it's a fairly simple application
and what we the core of what would
require are your transcripts and and
some residency documents uh so though
again these courses are open to people
globally um so the transcripts will be
all your educational transcripts we want
undergraduate if you've done a MERS or
PhD we'd want to see those as
well uh in terms of uh in terms of the
other requirements there is a statement
of purpose and I want to emphasize that
this is not a college essay this is not
if you you know applied to college or
went to college us where you spent like
you know months or weeks or whatever
trying to craft the perfect uh college
essay this is not that we just are
looking for a few sentences to describe
what your goals are as a as a learner
and and in terms of pursuing this topic
and other topics through Stanford online
through scpd and then uh it's also a
great opportunity for you to provide
some more context to your professional
experience or educational background in
order to help the people who are
reviewing your application understand
how you meet prerequisites for the
course so let me explain that in a
little bit more detail as I mentioned uh
for management science and engineering
that introduction to product management
they love everyone to have multivariable
calculus they think that's a baseline in
terms of mathematical maturity that's
necessary for the kinds of courses they
offer that's probably going to be on
your transcript as just something like
math 101 it's great to add that in your
statement of purpose and say you know I
meet the multivariable calculus
requirement Through Math 101 in my
undergraduate transcript you can see it
you know here another good example is if
you are interested in maybe not a
product management course but a computer
science course and it requires python
but you never took python uh you know in
college you might at this point say hey
look I never took python but I've been a
working programmer for six years I use
Python extensively I feel confident I
would be able to you know manage uh
manage the python requirements here so
that's something that you can really add
in the statement of of purpose and then
finally you submit a request to enroll
in a course and again every time you
enroll that application will be reviewed
you don't need to submit the application
we keep it on file and the department
will review and then uh you know if
you're a good fit for the course you
meet the requirements then they then
they would approve that and you would
take the course now one other thing I'll
add is is we it's a big commitment I
know nine to 15 hours a week and
sometimes you you enroll with the best
of intentions and then the first week of
class a project comes up at work and you
just you can't you know you're not going
to be able to make that kind of time
commitment to both work or family uh as
well as the course you have three weeks
to drop the course uh and you will get a
full refund on the tuition minus a $100
drop fee if you drop before the course
begins you get a full refund there's no
drop fee so there is an opportunity for
you to enroll to kind of try the course
out for a week or two because we know
it's a big commitment we know it's
really hard it's really rigorous and we
all start the online learning with the
best of intentions um but it's not
always uh you know things come up life
happens so that's and that drop policy
is specific to the credit bearing
programs it's not true for the
professional programs they different
drop policies but I wanted to um let you
know that so I'm going to stop here and
see if there's um if there
are um if there are some questions here
and so let me see were any of these
courses taught in person before 20120 so
uh to to be clear that's a great
question the credit bearing courses are
all still taught in person on Stanford's
campus we just allow professional
Learners who are non Stanford uh you
know not matriculated Stanford students
to also join the courses as online
Learners right so there there's there
the teachers are addressing two
audiences essentially the oncampus
students as well as the online students
they you're doing the same work you're
in the same class you're a student you
know you're a student at Stanford you're
you're getting a Stanford transcript you
would get a Stanford email you'd get
your your Stanford login credential so
you can access all the online resources
but you're just pursuing it in parallel
next to uh next to alongside not in
parallel you're pursuing it alongside
the on C courses the start dates are
January 8th for both of these credit
bearing programs um and again it the um
the actually I think this is probably my
next slide I hope I thought ah yes great
so uh if you are interested to apply for
the winter quarter for either these two
courses or any of the other courses that
we offer in winter quarter the
application is due by December 8th we
also again uh we'll we'll uh open
courses for spring enrollment and those
open on February 5th we don't have any
specific specific product management
courses available in Spring but there
are plenty of other uh similar courses
and of course a lot of engineering
courses also
available are there uh so let's see here
what's uh let's see if there are some
more questions
here so great question about entry level
is we're talking about the so I think
any of these offerings would be
appropriate for entry level students is
that fair Liz in terms of the
professional offerings I think if you're
new to product management all these are
going to you know would be a good place
to start I think what you will want to
ask yourself is what you are ready to
make a time commitment for and how how
interested you are and how much you want
to learn from these topics so again if
you're thinking about an individual
course that you can take through the
professional program that's a you know
that's a nine to 10 hour commitment you
can move through your own pace you can
work through that material again a great
way to just get familiar with it if
you're doing the accelerated program
with professional course that's a again
a 10-week commitment I think it's about
40 hours of work is that right Liz so
about four hours a week if you're doing
the graduate courses uh you're you're
going to uh you're going to be working
again 10 weeks but probably closer to
that nine to 10 15 hours a week so it's
a it's a much bigger commitment and so
it's really about how ready you are how
ready how much and how in- depth you
want to go into this
topic um is there a stronger Focus on
technology product management that's a
great question uh it is true both both
of those courses will focus on
technology product management so as
opposed to maybe something like a
fashion product management again that's
the experience and uh background of a
non a non JZ and for management science
and engineering that is a a department
so for the product management
fundamentals with a non njz their
background is in in software right and
with the uh though they do focus on also
sort of real infrastructure typee
projects and then with the um with the
fundamentals is also you know a focus on
technological product management however
the principles you learn in those
courses could apply more broadly to any
kind of product management position you
have both of them all the courses that
we're talking about introduce Frameworks
and and one way I know that Anan and
Jay-Z who are again the principal
instructors for both the professional as
well as one of the graduate courses the
way they frame it is that product
management is really a uh a problem
solving strategy a way of approaching a
certain problem understanding what the
problem is designing a solution and then
there may be some kind of specific
business things when you get into a
launch plan and a road mapap but they're
really useful Frameworks um you know I I
will say and Liz can second this I use
some of the material from these courses
and thinking through my own role so I
find it very
useful um so for the academic courses
for credit web percentage of people on
average get accepted for a course I
don't have acceptance rates um but again
it's you know there there's no cost to
apply um I would you know um and if you
you're you're denied or you are uh you
decide to drop you know before the the
course begins there's a full
refund uh let's see there are some other
courses six months program weekend study
uh
as a mechanical engineer can I use them
in in my field I think the uh the answer
would you know again that's going to
depend and and I think a great way to
get a sense of this as Liz said is to
join the program preview one thing I
will add is that Anan who is the
principal uh one of the principal
instructors both the professional as
well as the one of The Graduate classes
is a was his background is mechanical
engineering and he moved into product
management
um and then let's see here um we have
some some questions about the the group
projects um so there there so I think
Liz if you want do you want to talk a
little bit about the group project for
the professional courses and then I can
talk about what I know for the group
projects for the uh the on campus
courses sure credit bearing yeah so for
the group projects for the um so group
projects are only in the accelerated
program and it's really up to your group
to decide your Cadence and how you meet
so sometimes there are groups who you
know there are people who want to work
with people local to them and sometimes
we can accommodate that and um I know in
the past there are groups who have met
up in person to work on assignments
together uh but oftentimes you know you
might be in different places but in in
the same time zone you would meet over
Zoom or whatever um software you want to
use to work together um different groups
have different cadences of how often
they like to meet I know some groups
like to meet once early in the week and
again right before they submit some
groups only meet once so it's just it's
you know really dependent on how you
like to work with other
people thanks Liz and then for the
credit bearing programs and let me slip
uh past this slide to uh to the summary
so we can we'll hang on this and then we
we'll we'll we'll talk through this
again but take a few more questions
right now in terms of uh the projects
and the the credit bearing so again
these change year-to year the exact kind
of structure and how they're processed
based on student feedback from the prior
year so for uh the product management
fundamentals uh the the sort of cadence
here is you're going to probably be in a
group of about four they try to pair
online students with other online
students they find that collaboration is
is more efficient uh and then you would
probably have a you know a deliverable
due every two to three weeks your team
would have a deliverable every two to
three weeks and I I laid out kind of uh
the structure of the what they're
calling the MVP project the minimum
viable projects there's probably a
there's a problem space uh deliverable
due then there is a design uh solution
solution design uh deliverable due and
then there is a a launch deliverable
then a road map and then there's a kind
of a final deliverable where you bring
all that together so it's a it's a
you're probably delivering something
every two two to two to uh two to three
weeks in the course the other one um
there are a couple check-ins and there
are a couple sort of deliverables due
along the way but to that and this is
again the introduction to project
management I know they're very similar
uh similar titles that one has weekly
check-ins in the middle or at least it
did has in the past so you would be
meeting briefly with the team you'd have
something deliverable due each week um
and and in the C middle of the class and
you'd be checking in with someone on the
teaching team so that they make sure
you're making progress towards the final
goal
um
uh so let's see there are a couple other
questions and then maybe I'll take two
more and then I I think Liz and I will
we'll wrap up here by going over kind of
a summary so there who are the
instructors so for the credit bearing
courses for the introduction to project
management it is Professor Edison SE in
the uh management science and
engineering program and for the
fundamentals of product management it is
Anand subani and Joana Zang who are also
uh two instructors in the professional
program
for the professional program again Anan
and Jay-Z are two of the principal
instructors in addition to that uh
Jonathan lvav who is a faculty member in
the GSB and Liz correct me if I'm wrong
in any of these um Michael lepic also
teaches in that program he is a
professor in the uh civil and
environmental engineering program and
then I believe is it Julie Stanford um
yes Julie Stanford who's an instructor
in computer science um and then also
Linda Smith um who uh teaches the demand
creation course and again those those
instructors are primarily their content
in the professional programs are
primarily delivered through pre-recorded
materials though in the accelerated
program some of them may join for
coaching or
or informational sessions
um so uh let's let's walk through one
more time uh and maybe this is actually
a good time I see there's some general
questions here um so let's just walk
through so uh Liz do you want to walk
through the your two the individual
courses and I'll access plan and the
product management and I'll go into the
credit bearing and I think in the
process of answering that we'll get to
some of the last questions here yeah
sure so um so focusing on the individual
courses and the all access plan so these
courses are self-paced you complete
assignments on your own timeline there's
no application you can start whenever is
convenient for you you can start today
right after after this info session or
you can decide um maybe have more free
time uh in the new year to start the
courses there's no peer-to-peer
interaction so there's no there's no
slot community in the self-paced
offering but there is support through um
the email Channel where you can um ask
your questions to the course
facilitators and the accelerated program
um it's instructor pace so we have a
specific start day so the next start dat
is January 31st it's offered three times
a year generally in the winter summer
and fall um you have weekly assignments
and there is a final Capstone um the
weekly assignments are due at the same
time every single week um there's a lot
more peer-to-peer interaction just
through working with your group towards
the assignments but also in the slack
Community where you know people will ask
different questions people will jump in
try and network with each other um and
then yeah I've touched on this a little
through the support but um you have
email slack and coaching session support
from the coaches
um and then there's that online
community of of everyone going through
the course together on
slack great Liz could you say when so
for the individual start any time when
does the uh uh registration close for
the product management accelerated
that's starting in the winter yeah so
the registration deadline for the uh
accelerate program is January 29th so
the week zero we we call it week zero
and it's kind of U you can think of it
as like an introductory week like on
boarding um that starts on January 31st
um right now we do have early bird
pricing for the accelerated program if
you enroll by December 17th but um the
deadline is January
29th great and then for the for the
credit bearing again these are this is a
uh weekly assignments and a final
project in both the the different
courses uh for the product management uh
they they this does require an
application as I went over it's a fairly
straightforward appli application the
start date here would be Janu around
January 8th it can depend I mean I think
if if the class is a Monday Wednesday or
Tuesday Thursday kind of class but the
start date is around January 8th and the
the Finish date would be around March
22nd if you're interested in enrolling
the application deadline for one of
these courses would be December 8th
again if you're interested in a spring
course you can you know create the
application at any time and then have it
reviewed uh for the spring course at a
later time in terms of the support uh
you know there are there are the
lectures these going to be you know
recorded live or in the case of
re-recorded you know each each week and
available uh on demand for you or in the
case of the uh fundamentals project
management it would be a a both recorded
as well as available to join Over Zoom
there are community of students that
you'd be joining and that's both in the
course as well as a slack community that
joins you with other uh other
professionals who are pursuing online
credit bearing courses at Stanford that
quarter um and there's of course there
is uh pure
interaction and in terms of the
certificate again that the certificate
for credit bearing is a graduate
certificate and that is a a certificate
that you that is accredited by wasque
for the product management accelerated
it is a certificate certificate of
achievement correct Liz and do you also
earn records of completion for the
individual courses within the program or
just the certificate of achievement no
it it's just for the accelerated program
it's just the certificate of achievement
if you pursue the all access plan and
you finish the the required courses for
the certificate you would earn a
certificate of completion as well as the
record of completion for the individual
courses is that correct that's correct
great okay um so we're just about at
time I'm I don't think we got to every
question um we have a lot of questions
about which one is right for you we hope
that the information we provided to you
today has given you a sense of the
different time commitments the different
sort of depth of material of coverage of
this material um and so you know the one
thing I would add end to this in terms
of deciding which one is right they all
cover similar types of material it's
really kind of the level you want to go
if you want to pick and choose right so
it's choosing what's right in terms of
your the time commitment you can make
and where you are right now so I would
encourage all of you if any of this
sounds interesting as Liz said is to
just go ahead and enroll in the program
preview um I believe there's a link to
it or to the product management um
program professional program where you
can find the the program preview should
be right there in your console so we
really appreciate all of you joining us
today thank you so much for being here
and all your questions and we hope to
see you uh virtually online or or uh in
the online
classroom